[Music]
the
16th meeting of the security council
is called to order
the provisional agenda for this meeting
is
threat to international peace and
security
the agenda
is
i give the floor to the
representative of the russian federation
foreign
foreign
uh
foreign
foreign
is
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
russian federation i give the floor to
the representative of the us
thank you very much madam president
as our colleague
stated
we have called for this meeting
and we've called for this meeting
because of what we have all witnessed
over the course of the past few months
in terms of the actions of the russian
federation on the territory
of on the border with ukraine
uh they indicate
that uh it's in their own territory
very
uh close to their
uh it's a neighbor that has been invaded
already before
it's a neighbor that has uh
russian troops occupying uh their
territory
uh we have had numerous meetings
over a hundred meetings over the course
of the past few weeks
both with
russian officials and in consultations
with our european and ukrainian
colleagues all of these meetings have
been in private we think it's now time
to have a meeting in public
and
have
this discussed in a public forum
uh we have uh worked with the ukrainians
at their request
to provide assistance to them so they
can prepare for what they see as
inevitable
including having provided 200 million
recent weeks and over
14 and that is so that they can be
prepared
uh you've heard from our russian
colleagues that we're calling for
this meeting to make you all feel
uncomfortable
imagine how uncomfortable you would be
if you had a hundred thousand troops
sitting on your border uh in the
way that these troops are sitting on the
border with ukraine
uh for us this is about peace and
security it's about honoring
the
u.n charter
that calls up on us as members of the
security council to protect peace and
security so this is not about antics uh
it's not about rhetoric it's not about
u.s and russia what this is about
is the insecurity of one of our member
states
i thank the representative
states
view of the request and the comments
made by members of the security council
i intend to put the provisional agenda
to a vote
accordingly i shall put it to the route
now
will those in favor of the adoption of
the provisional agenda please raise
their hand
those against
abstention
the result of the voting is
the provisional agenda has been adopted
in accordance with rule 37 of the
council provisionals of procedure
i invite the representative of belarus
lithuania poland and ukraine to
participate in this meeting
it is so decided
in accordance with rule 39
additional rules or procedure i invite
mr
general for political and peace building
affairs to persist participate in the
meeting
it is so decided
the security council will now begin its
consideration of item two of the agenda
recalling the security council latest
note 507 on its working methods i wish
to encourage all speakers both members
and non-members of the council to
deliver the statements in five minutes
or less
note 507 also encouraged briefers to be
succinct and to focus on key issues in
this spirit briefers are further
encouraged to limit their initial
remarks to 7 to 10 minutes everyone is
also
wearing a mask at all times including
while they're real deli
i now give the floor to rosemary hollow
thank you
madam president
following the ongoing diplomatic
discussions on the future of european
peace and security architecture
among representatives of the russian
federation the united states
members of the north atlantic treaty
organization the european union and the
organization for the security and
cooperation in europe
we hope the outcome of these talks will
strengthen peace and security in europe
including for ukraine
madam president although not an active
participant in these exchanges
in all his contacts the secretary
general has unequivocally
supported the ongoing diplomatic efforts
at all levels
still
we remainly concerned that
even as these efforts
tensions keep escalating
in a dangerous
is in the heart of europe
reported that over 100 000 troops and
heavy weaponry from the russian
federation are positioned along the
border with ukraine unspecified numbers
of russian troops and weaponry are also
reportedly being deployed to belarus
ahead of large-scale joint military
exercises in february on the borders
with ukraine poland and the baltic
states
nato members are reportedly plenaries
actors involved in the ongoing
discussions
have created uncertainty and
apprehension for many that a military
confrontation
is impending
madam president
the secretary journal has made clear
that there can be no alternative
to diplomacy and dialogue to deal with
the complex long-standing security
concerns
and threat perceptions that have been
raised
he has expressed his strong belief that
there should not be any military
intervention in this context and that
diplomacy should prevail
he's been equally explicit that any such
intervention by one country in another
would be against international law and
the united nations charter
his expectation is that we all
contribute to avoiding confrontation and
to creating conditions for a diplomatic
solution to end this crisis
we therefore welcome the steps taken so
far by all involved to maintain dialogue
we urge and expect all actors to build
on these efforts and to remain focused
on pursuing diplomatic solutions by
engaging in good faith
we further urge all actors to refrain
from provocative rhetoric and actions
to maximize the chance for diplomacy to
succeed
achieving mutual understanding and
lasting mutually acceptable arrangements
is the best way to safeguard regional
and international peace and security in
the interest of all
madam president
let me repeat the full commitment of the
united nations to the sovereignty
political independence unity and
territorial integrity of ukraine within
its internationally recognized borders
in accordance with relevant general
assembly resolutions
it is important especially at this time
for the international community to
intensify its support for the efforts of
the normandy 4 and of the osce-led
trilateral contact group
to ensure the implementation of the
minsk agreements
endorsed by this council in its
resolution
2202
we welcome the recent meeting of the
normandy for advisors in paris
and their agreement to reconvene shortly
in berlin as another sign that diplomacy
can work
we commend these efforts and those of
the osce special monitoring mission
likewise united nations agencies in
ukraine are committed to continue
delivering on their mandates in
accordance with the humanitarian
principles
of neutrality impartiality humanity and
independence
safe unimpeded humanitarian access
must be respected under any
circumstances
to provide support to the 2.9 million
people in need of assistance
with the majority and non-government
non-government-controlled areas
in this regard i encourage member states
to contribute to the humanitarian
response plan
further the u.n human rights monitoring
mission in ukraine continues to document
civilian casualties in the conflict area
madam president no one is watching the
current diplomatic efforts more than the
people of ukraine
they have endured a conflict that has
taken over 14 000 lives since 2014
and that tragically is still far from
resolution
it is painfully obvious
that any new escalation in or around
ukraine would mean more needless killing
and destruction
whatever one's position
regarding the current situation or the
status of the status quo in eastern
ukraine
this should be inconceivable
the fact that it is not should give us
pause
the principles enshrined in the un
charter the helsinki final act and
multiple other commitments to safeguard
regional and international peace and
security are crystal clear
any escalation or new conflict would
deal another serious blow to the
architecture so painstakingly built up
over the last 75 years
to maintain international peace and
security
just when we need it most
once again i'd like to stress the
secretary general's appeal to all
concerned to take immediate steps to
de-escalate tensions and continue on the
diplomatic path
the united nations stands ready to
support our to support all efforts to
that end thank you madam president
i thank rose mali de carlo for her
briefing
i now give the floor to those council
members who wish to make statements
i give the floor to the representative
of the united states
thank you madam president and thank you
under secretary general decalo for your
briefing
colleagues the situation we're facing in
europe is urgent and dangerous
and the stakes for ukraine
and for every u.n member state could not
be
higher
russia's actions strike at the very
heart
of the u.n charter
this is as clear and consequential a
threat to peace and security as anyone
can imagine
in the wake of world war ii
the council was formed to address
precisely the kind of threat that
ukraine now faces
as article 39 says
the security council shall determine the
existence of any threat
to the peace
thus our charge is not only to address
conflicts
after they occur but also to prevent
them from happening in the first place
this is why today's meeting is so
crucial
russia's aggression today not only
threaten ukraine
it also threatens europe
it threatens the international order
this body is charged with upholding
an order that if it stands for anything
stands for the principle that one
country cannot simply redraw another
country's borders by force
or make another country's people live
under a government they did not choose
we continue to hope russia chooses the
path of diplomacy
over the path of conflict in ukraine
but we cannot just wait and see
it is crucial that this council address
the risk that their aggressive and
destabilizing behavior poses across the
globe
first let's be clear about the facts
russia has
service
this is the primary audio circuit for
the reuters live service
offensive actions into ukraine
this is the largest this is the largest
hear me clearly mobilization of troops
in europe in decades
and as we speak russia is sending even
more forces and arms to join them
russia has already used more than 2 000
rail cars to move troops and weaponry
from across russia to the ukrainian
border
russia has also moved nearly 5 000
troops into belarus with short-range
ballistic missiles special forces and
anti-aircraft
we've seen evidence that russia intends
to expand
to more than thirty thousand troops near
the belarus
two hours north of kiev by early
february
in addition to military activity we've
also seen a dramatic spike in cyber
attacks on ukraine in recent weeks
russian military and intelligence
services are spreading disinformation
through state-owned media and proxy
sites
and they are attempting without any
factual basis to paint ukraine and
western countries as the aggressors to
fabricate a pretext for attack
russia's military buildup on the border
has been paired with extensive new
demands and aggressive rhetoric
this is an escalation and a pattern of
aggression that we've seen from russia
again and again
in 2014
russia
invaded and seized crimea
she invaded georgia
hoping to depart moldova despite the
wishes of the moldovan people and their
democratically elected government
and in the donbass region of ukraine
russian-backed separatists continue to
foment and ignore violence toward the
ukrainian people
recently russia has threatened to take
military action should its demands not
be met
if russia further invades ukraine none
of us
will be able to say we didn't see it
coming
and the consequences will be horrific
which is why this meeting is so
important today
already russians russia's war in eastern
ukraine has killed more than fourteen
thousand ukrainians nearly three million
ukrainians half of whom are elderly
people and children need food
assistance
devastating
is
it would pill in comparison
of the full-scale land invasion russia
is currently planning in ukraine
over the years russian leaders have
claimed that ukraine is not a real
country and question is right to
self-determination
so let's be clear
ukraine is a u.n member state that
recently celebrated three decades of
independence
it has a proud people
and a rich culture
ukraine is a sovereign country and a
sovereign people entitled to determine
their own future without the threat of
force this is not just the conviction
that ukrainians hold it is a right
enshrined by the u.n
a right that russia and every other
member of
has freely committed to upholding
order is not perfect
but it is
end countries to govern themselves to
defend themselves and to associate with
whom they choose
all countries have a stake
in defending and preserving these
principles
and nothing could be more fundamental
what would it mean
for the world if former empires had
license to start reclaiming territory by
force
this would set us down a dangerous
path
russia could of course choose a
different path
the path of diplomacy
in recent weeks the united states along
with our european allies and partners
and other nations around the globe
continues threat to ukraine have
continued to do
can to resolve this crisis peace
these talks our messages have been clear
and consistent
we seek the path of peace
we seek the path of dialogue
we do not want confrontation
but we will be decisive swift and united
should russia further invade ukraine
we continue to believe there is a
diplomatic path
out of the crisis caused by russia's
unprovoked military buildup
we're working to pursue diplomacy in
every possible venue
but we also know that diplomacy will not
succeed
in an atmosphere of threat
and military escalation
that
we have brought this situation before
the security council
the united states has been clear
about russia's security concerns in
europe
opportunity to address these concerns
at the negotiating table
the test of russia's good faith in the
coming days and weeks is whether they
will come to that table
and stay at that table until we reach an
understanding
if they refuse to do so the world will
know why
and who is responsible
fellow members of the council and other
u.n member states we urge you to assess
not only russia's statements but their
actions with clear eyes
to evaluate the risk this pres
this presents not just to ukraine's
border and its people
but to all of us
and to speak clearly and forcefully in
favor a path of diplomacy
rather than the path of con
madam president
i thank the representative
and i give the floor to the
representative of albania
thank you madam president for convening
this open meeting and thank you under
secretary general dicarlo for your
briefing
madam president
the primary responsibility of the
security council is to maintain peace
and security with a view to preventing
conflicts in the world
we have argued here several times that
in terms of prevention the council has
still a long way to go
the council has been seized many times
to discuss the situation in ukraine
since the beginning of the aggression in
2014 and here we are again today
we express our deep concerns on the
military buildup of russia near ukraine
in recent months
dozens of battalions have been already
dislocated to the ukrainian border
military troops are being dis
to western part of russia
this includes
artillery
air defense
several thousands of russian troops have
also been sent to belarus
this movement of troops and weaponry
weaponry is very worrying has caused
anxiety and fear among people in ukraine
and justifiably serious international
concerns particularly for us in europe
madam president let me reconfirm our
unwavering support for the sovereignty
and territorial integrity of ukraine
within its internationally recognized
borders
dear colleagues
in 1994
27 years ago ukraine received security
assurances through the budapest
memorandum
where russia together with us and uk
pledged and i quote respect the
independence and sovereignty and the
existing border
in exchange for giving up its nuclear
the signatories also reaffirmed their
council action to provide assistance to
ukraine
should it become a victim of an act of
aggression
we call on russia and the security
council to expressly confirm the respect
of the sovereignty and territorial
integrity of ukraine
madam president
it would be wrong to consider the threat
of a military attack by russia against
ukraine as another crisis between russia
and the west
this is a challenge to the european
security order and to the whole
international security architecture
which is based on the u.n charter
it is an affront to the 1975 helsinki
final act and its decalogue upon which
osce is founded and where russia is a
part
these last developments on the
border are a well-known playbook
we have
georgia in 2008. and in ukraine
unfortunately at the cost of thousands
of lives civilian and military
russia has used military violence as a
means of achieving its political and
geopolitical goals
madam president
russia is a big country and has a role
to play in european and world
geopolitics
it can play an important part in making
the world a better and a safer place
unfortunately is it is doing the country
the narratives of spheres of influence
in europe or dictating by threats the
geostrategic orientation of other
countries are tools of another century
of another time reminiscences of the
cold war
countries are and should be free to join
whichever organization they want be it
nato the european union csto or
sovereign countries take decisions by
their free will
under the threat of a gun
man
in a potential conflict to which
everyone anticipates the disastrous
consequences
what can justify the loss of thousands
of lives widespread destruction
severence of relations continued
tensions
including at this has been made
repeatedly clear
severe consequences for russia itself
no other place
knows more about war and its disastrous
consequences than this room
therefore we must be able to see beyond
and seek other means to address issues
however complex they are or seem to be
albena believes that this crisis should
be solved through talks and discussion
finding solutions through negotiations
was our primary focus during the osce
chairmanship in office in 2020
it remains the same now in the council
mechanisms to be used through diplomatic
efforts
concrete
are needed paving the ground towards
talks
such efforts should be made in good
faith and not be conducted in a climate
of escalation rhetoric
the resumption of the normandy format
meetings last week in paris was the
right step and we hope that this process
will continue
madam president
we all should bear in mind that the
crisis in and around ukraine has a
direct impact on the whole europe
the instrumentalization of ethnic
minorities
targeted cyber attacks
political interference here and there
for political gains
and a growing tendency of genocide
denial and glorification on war crimes
and war criminals
all these acts that are all these are
acts that seek the stabilization create
tension and should be treated threat
peace and security because they are
this is
of paramount importance to invest in
prevention this meeting will be part of
such genuine efforts and i thank
the representative of albania and i give
the floor to the representative of the
united kingdom
thank you madam presidents and i'm
grateful to under secretary general de
carlo for her briefing
madam president
the first article of the un charter
defines our purpose here
to take collective measures for the
prevention and removal of threats to the
peace
today
over a hundred thousand russian troops
are massed on ukraine's borders
they are equipped with tanks
armored vehicles
rocket artillery
and short-range ballistic missiles
they are supported by russian air and
maritime long-range strike capabilities
this is not a routine deployment
this is the largest military buildup in
europe in decades
in the best case scenario the scope
madam president in 2008 russia told this
council that it was sending peacekeepers
into georgia
in reality it was invading an
independent democratic country
in 2014
russia denied to this council the
presence of its forces in crimea
in reality
its soldiers were annexing part of an
independent democratic ukraine
today russia denies that its forces are
posing a threat to ukraine
but yet again we see disinformation
cyber attacks
and destabilizing plots directed against
an independent democratic country
madam president the united kingdom
welcomes our
part of the intense diplomatic efforts
to ensure
the situation and avoids conflict
unwavering in our support for ukraine's
sovereignty
independence and territorial integrity
at the same time we have sought dialogue
with russia through the osce the
nato-russia council and bilateral
discussions with all levels of the
russian government
we are ready to address mutual security
concerns
based on existing european security
structures and international commitments
this includes our expectation that
russia should address our concerns
we are committed to a constructive
dialogue if russia is genuine about
finding a diplomatic solution
this council has a vital interest in
this diplomatic effort
because let's be clear this is not a
regional issue
any russian invasion or act of
aggression against ukraine
of international law
and russia's commitments
conflict would
destabilize the entire international
community
there should be no doubt about how
costly such a miscalculation would be
for russia
or how devastating it would be for the
people of ukraine
whose only provocation is to want a
democratic future for their country
there will be no winners only victims
civilians caught in the crossfire
were forced to flee
families grieving the loss of fallen
soldiers on both sides
so madam president we urge russia to
make clear in this council
that it will abide by its obligations
under the charter
that it has no plans to invade ukraine
that it will refrain from the threat
or use of force against its neighbor
further undermine ukraine's sovereignty
or territorial integri
by military or any other means
thank you madam president
united kingdom i give the floor to the
representative of france
territorial
vous de merci
i thank the representative of france and
i give the floor to the representative
of india
thank you madam president
we have been closely following the
evolving developments relating to
ukraine
including through ongoing high-level
security talks between the russian
federation and the united states
as well as under the normandy format in
paris
india's interest is in finding a
solution
that can provide for immediate
de-escalation of tensions
taking into account the legitimate
security interests of all countries
and aimed towards securing long-term
peace and stability in the region and
beyond
we have also been in touch with all
concerned parties
it is our considered view that the
issues can only be resolved through
diplomatic dialogue
in this context we welcome the efforts
underway including under the minsk
agreement and the normandy format
flowing from the recently concluded
meeting in paris under the normandy
format we also welcome the unconditional
observance of the july 2020 ceasefire
and reaffirmation of minsk agreements as
the basis of work under the ongoing
normandy format in particular
commitment of all sides to reduce
disagreements on the way forward
we also welcome their agreement to meet
in berlin in two weeks
we urge all parties to continue to
engage
through all diplomatic channels and to
keep working towards the full
implementation of the men's package
quiet and constructive diplomacy is the
need of the r
any steps that increase tension may best
be avoided by all sides in the larger
interest of securing international peace
and security
more than 20 000 indian students and
nationals live and study in different
parts of ukraine including in its border
areas
the well-being of indian national is a
priority to us
madam president i reiterate our call for
the peaceful resolution of the situation
by sincere and sustained diplomatic
efforts to ensure that concerns of all
sides are resolved through constructive
dialogue i thank you madam president
thank the representative of india and i
give the floor to the representative of
ghana
thank you very much madam president
a few moments ago this council voted to
adopt the agenda for this meeting to
consider the situation in ukraine
our responsibility for the maintenance
of international peace and security
makes it imperative to encourage the
part of dialogue and preventive
diplomacy that is the only way to end
the tensions
bridge the differences between the
parties and forge a unified and pacific
position
on the situation you're occurring
let me begin by thanking rosemary
dicarlo usg for political affairs and
peace building
for the briefing
i also welcome the participation
of the representatives of ukraine
belarus poland and lithuania in this
meeting
ghana has been following closely the
situation in ukraine
i've also listened carefully to the
briefing we just received from the
secretariat
as well as the statement of delegations
that have spoken before me
we have paid careful attention to the
perspectives of the key parties to the
situation
and hope that at the end of this meeting
the views of members of this council
will be closer to each other than when
we first began
we note from the situation ukraine that
while there has been a buildup of
russian troops at the internationally
recognized borders of ukraine
those troops are presently revealing the
national charity of the russian
federation
we also have taken note that while the
military buildup of the troops of the
russian federation have in its borders
this has caused for ukraine and other
parties a concern over the intentions of
the buildup
and its prospective implications on
international peace and security
we therefore welcome the ongoing
dialogue between the russian federation
and the united states to address primary
secondary security concerns
that have implications on the situation
in ukraine
as well as the recent face-to-face
dialogue between the representatives of
the russian federation and ukraine under
the normandy format in paris after
several months of no contact
to enhance trust and remove
possibilities of an accidental incident
we know to concern the implications the
situation has had on the economy of
ukraine and neighboring markets
and welcome in this regard a call by the
president of ukraine for an easing of
the strong narratives on the situation
this must be a time for confidence
building to facilitate a restoration of
normalcy
for the people of ukraine
in concluding madame preston ghana
believes that in conformity
with the provisions of the charter of
this organization
differences between member states should
only be resolved through peaceful means
we remain encouraged by the ongoing
diplomatic engagement between the
parties
and reiterate our support for those
efforts we should also take into account
the delicate nature of the situation
i thank you very much for your kind
attention
i thank the representative of ghana i
give the floor to the representative of
ireland
thank you very much madam president and
thanks also to under secretary general
dicarlo for your briefing
madam president today's discussion is an
important opportunity for the council to
address the developing situation at
ukraine's borders which has become a
matter of profound international concern
let me underline at the outset that
ireland along with our eu partners is a
strong and unwavering supporter of
ukraine's independence
sovereignty and territorial integrity
within its internationally recognized
borders
at this moment of rising tension on
ukraine's frontiers arising from
russia's military buildup
ireland calls for calm
de-escalation and the pursuit of
diplomacy
we call also for constructive and
determined engagement on all dialogue
tracks including the normandy format
and the osce
ireland is fully committed to the core
principles enshrined in the un charter
these include the sovereign equality and
territorial integrity of states
we recall today that these principles
were agreed collectively and freely by
all members of the united nations
moreover european security is built on a
series of essential commitments and
obligations
is the fundamental right of a sovereign
and independent state to chart its own
path in the world
to choose its own foreign policy
and to make arrangements for the
security and defense of its territory
the helsinki final act one of the
foundational documents of the osce
confirms the obligation of states and i
quote to respect each other's sovereign
equality
and the right of every state to
juridical equality to territorial
integrity and to freedom and political
independence end of quote
subsequent agreements including the
charter of paris and the charter of
european security agreed in istanbul in
1999
reaffirmed the core principles and
underpinning collective european
security
madam president
earlier this month ireland marked 100
years of a hard-won independence
just as we would not accept another
state determining our foreign and
security policy ukraine similarly has
the sovereign right to choose its own
policies
faced with the terrible humanitarian
consequences
of violent conflict usually where
diplomacy and dialogue have failed
force is never the answer
it is not the answer now
what is needed now above all is a
negotiated diplomatic solution
that reinforces our collective security
in europe
we have the institutions and the
mechanisms within which to pursue this
solution
let us use them
absent that it will be innocent
civilians who once again pay the awful
price of conflict
madam president that is not a prospect
any of us wish to contemplate
thank you
i thank the representative of ireland
and i give the floor to the
representative of china
soon
says
[Music]
foreign
i thank the representative of china and
i give the floor to the representative
of the russian federation
um
is
uh
is
to make your words
foreign
foreign
ukraine
foreign
uh
um
foreign
is
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
substances
foreign
foreign
um
foreign
i thank the representative of the
russian federation i give the floor to
the representative of gabon
the secretary
rosemarie
relatively
an important activity diplomatic history
different initiative don't look forward
normandy
down the cardinal
situation attention particularly
negotiation
diplomacy
i thank the representative of gabor and
i give the floor to the representative
of brazil
thank you very much madam president and
let me also
thank usg rosemary de carlo for the
briefing he has put forward
to the council this morning
due political tensions and threats to
international peace and security
require the security council to engage
promptly and timely
open references to military actions
unilateral economic sanctions and other
measures
are developments that should be avoided
under the un charter
the security council must fulfill its
primary objective which is to prevent
war
there is an a general and urgent need to
resort to meaningful dialogue with
and between the parties directly
involved in the escalation of tensions
we urge all parties to exercise maximum
restraint and to engage constructively
in talks aimed at resolving their
differences
there is room to restore confidence and
find a lasting diplomatic solution to
this crisis
for that
we need political will
and genuine commitment from all sides
brazil encourages all parties to
strictly observe international law
it is imperative to apply the principles
enshrined in the charter consistently
in a non-selective manner
the prohibition of use of force the
peaceful resolution of disputes
and the principles of sovereignty
territorial integrity and the protection
of human rights are pillars of our
collective security system
brazil also highlights the need for good
faith
in order to address legitimate security
concerns of all parties
including russia's and ukraine's
we encourage parties to pursue genuine
talks on the implementation of the minsk
agreements
security council resolution 2202
which provided useful guidelines to
address the situation is eastern ukraine
is also a valuable tool
in the diplomatic efforts to overcome
the situation
brazil welcomes the resumption of talks
in the normandy format
and the renewed commitment to the
ceasefire in eastern ukraine
despite the sensitive and difficult
nature of the issue on our agenda today
i would like to conclude with a note of
hope
it has been encouraging to hear
over the past few days statements to the
effect that there is no military
solution to the situation
at this moment in particular
this should be the motto of the whole
united nations membership
and of the security council
for a renewed commitment to diplomacy
and prevention i thank you madam
president
i thank the representative of brazil and
i give the floor to the representative
of kenya
thank you madam president uh for giving
me the floor and also for the able way
in which you have
presided over the security council in
the month of january
i thank under secretary general rosemary
dicarlo for her briefing
and i welcome the participation of the
representatives of ukraine
belarus lithuania and poland
kenya abstained on the procedural vote
to hold this meeting
we did so to reflect our contention
that the main issue in question here
is the impasse between nato and the
russian federation
we believe that it is imminently
solvable
and that the diplomatic steps underway
already show promise
this rather than escalation
in search of a winner-take-all
outcome
is what is required
to support and protect international
peace and security
kenya has always maintained that the
respect for the territorial integrity
and sovereignty of all countries is a
cornerstone of global peace
where there are disputes regarding
territorial jurisdiction
or security interests
we strongly support patient
diplomacy as the first second and third
options
when the dispute is between major powers
and regards the security of a third
country
it is imperative that they embrace a
spirit of compromise
we believe that the united states nato
and the russian federation
have an opportunity to establish a
diplomatic framework
that will allow them to resolve their
differences
their security and that of the entire
world
depends on them willingly taking this
step
not in ushering in
a new age of containment
provocation
and proxy actions
compromise is not surrender
the special powers given to the security
council's prominent members
demands that they embrace this principle
if the united nations is not to go the
way
of the doomed league of nations
africa recalls the rejections of
compromise
and the search for total victory that
led to the cold war
we experienced that cold war as a series
of hot wars
and interventions
that deeply damaged our dreams
for peace
development and competent inclusive
government
our internal divisions and fragilities
were weaponized at the altar of
geopolitical rivalry
it confirmed the truth of the african
saying that recognizes
when elephants fight
it is the grass that suffers
madam president
given that the majority of the conflict
situations
the security council deals with are in
africa
we do not want them to serve as
surrogates for a new cold war
we in africa therefore
have a direct stake in de-escalation
and renewed faith in diplomacy
we have serious challenges to solve
together
rarely has the world more urgently
needed a united nations that can deliver
ambitiously
madam president
kenya believes that there is still
plenty of opportunity
for the normandy former talks
the trilateral contact group on ukraine
and the direct negotiations between the
united states and the russian federation
to produce a satisfactory outcome
we urge all these parties to ensure that
their negotiations
respect the security
sovereignty and territorial integrity of
ukraine
faith in innovative diplomacy
may also allow for agreements between
today's major powers
inspired by the 1975 helsinki accords
which did deliver some stability to
europe
during the cold war
this time however
such agreements need to advance the
principle of non-interference to other
parts of the world and particularly to
africa
madam president
in closing
it is critical that diplomacy and its
acceptance of compromise as an
inevitable outcome win the day
if there are future discussions to be
held in the security council on this
matter
let it be to announce a new era of
cooperation
i thank you
i thank the representative of kenya and
i give the floor to the representative
of mexico
mucha gracias senora president
secretary general junta di carlos
existed
normandia
de la fuerza
i thank the representative of mexico and
i give the floor to the representative
of the united arab emirates
[Music]
i thank the representative of the united
arab emirates
i shall now make a statement in my
capacity as representative of norway
let me start by expressing norway's
strong support for ukraine's sovereignty
and territorial integrity within its
internationally recognized borders this
includes the crimean
peninsula and its territorial waters
norway is deeply concerned about the
russian large-scale military buildup
near the ukraine's border and in
occupied crimea this is unprovoked and
unjustified further escalation can have
devastating humanitarian consequences
through it harsh statement and
unrealistic demands russia now
challenges the security architecture in
all of europe the crisis therefore not
only affects the region but represents a
clear threat to international peace and
security
russia has repeatedly accused nato of
increasing tensions i would like to
underline that the alliance is defensive
and voluntary we do not seek
confrontation at the same time we cannot
and will not compromise on the
principles on which the security in
europe rests we stand ready to discuss
security concerns
norway support the european security
order based on international law and
national sovereignty we cannot allow
this to be replaced by spheres of
influence every country has the right to
freely choose its security alignment
we call on russia to de-escalate and to
engage constructively in dialogue
through the established international
mechanisms in good faith furthermore
furthermore norway underlines its
support for the existing international
frameworks for the sustainable and
peaceful resolution of conflicts in
accordance with international law
russia has itself repeatedly invoked in
many other councils discussing the
principles of respect for sovereignty
and territorial integrity norway calls
on russia do you know respect these
principles when it comes to ukraine
thank you
i shall now give the floor to the
representative of the united states who
has asked for the floor to make a
further statement
good thank you madam president
i can't say that i am surprised by my
russian colleagues comments but i am
disappointed
madam president
i cannot let the false equivalency
uh go unchecked so i uh i i feel i must
respond
let me be clear there are no plans to
weaken russia as claimed by our russian
colleague today
on the contrary we welcome russia as a
responsible member of the international
community
but its actions on the border of ukraine
are not responsible
the threats of aggression on the border
of ukraine
yes on its border is provocative
our recognition of the facts on the
ground
is not provocative
the threats of action if russia's
security demands aren't met is
provocative
our encouraging diplomacy is not
provocative
the provocations from russia not from us
or other members of this council
we have made clear our commitment to the
path of diplomacy i hope our russian
colleagues will also choose this path
and engage peacefully with the
international community including
ukraine
i say to russia simply this
your actions will speak for themselves
and we hope and encourage that you make
the right choices before this council
today thank you very much
i thank the representative of the united
states i give the floor to the
representative of the russian federation
who has talked about it
okay
all right
context that we need to use when we're
talking about the ukrainian crisis the
u.s
is looking at this from a completely
different
university
security council have to meet with the
secretary
so i can't change this situation because
of the sg's timetable so i'm gonna have
to leave i do apologize thank you
i thank the representative of the
russian federation
i wish now then to again remind all
speakers to limit their statement to no
more than five minutes in order to
enable the council to carry out this
work expeditiously
i now give the floor to the
representative of ukraine
well thank you madam president i would
like immediately to apologize that i may
not be
within the five-minute limits especially
giving the lengths of the russian
intervention
i would like to express my gratitude to
the norwegian presidency for calling
this briefing of the security council
of the need of which i spoke exactly a
fortnight ago
with her excellency foreign minister of
norway
during our meeting here in new york
i express our thanks to the u.s
who as a
member of the security council
in close coordination with ukraine
and partners
requested today's briefing
and of course i express our appreciation
of the presentation by under secretary
dicarlo
it's a duty and need for the security
council to be fully informed
in case of grave threats to
international peace and security
what is going on along the border with
ukraine where the russian federation
continues its military buildup falls
under the above qualification
it is important that ukraine's vote is
heard today in the security council
and is not lost in translation
when the position of my country has been
delivered by a foreign ambassador in the
russian language
i would ask the deputy of vasily
alexeyewicz
to tell him
that my leadership speaks its language
has its own ambassadors
and spokespersons
so there is no need to interpret the
words of ukrainian officials in a
foreign language
especially if it is done the way humpty
dumpty
balti spoke of the meaning of the wolves
even if lewis carroll
appears to be a favorite writer of the
russian top diplomats
against the backdrop of unprecedented
sequence of high-level diplomatic
contacts
in the past few weeks
a serious talk in the security council
is required more than ever
to present facts to listen to each
other's positions and concerns
as well as to outline further actions
towards the escalation
the fact is that nowadays about 112 000
russian troops have been amassed around
ukraine's borders and in crimea
and together
with the maritime and aviation
components their number reaches about
130 000.
another fact is that the russian troops
are also being deployed to belarus
for the union result 2022 joint drills
to be held on 10th
to 20th february
they include in particular iskandar
missile divisions as for hundred
trillion fan panzer anti-aircraft
systems sukhoi 35 generation 4 plus plus
fighters
on top of that on 26 january the russian
fleet started another military drill in
the black sea
with involvement of
patrol ships missile ships assault
landing ships and mine sweepers
this reminds us of the ongoing heavy
militarization
of the temporarily occupied crimea the
black sea and the sea of azov by russia
which poses a serious threat to ukraine
all
literal states and thereby the region
significant reinforcement of combat
capabilities of the russian occupation
forces in donbass
is another worrying trend
currently
the information
permissions consist of up to 35 000
personnel
including around 3 000 servicemen of the
russian armed forces
on command post and in other critical
combat positions
in the border areas outside government
control illegal border crossings by
cargo trains and truck convoys
delivering armed supplies to the russian
armed formations in donbass is a routine
practice
oec smm reports provide ample evidence
of various illegal activities in the
border areas
no surprise the restrictions of the oec
smm freedom of movement are on the
increase
in particular in
non-government-controlled areas close to
the ukraine russia border
on the 22nd december 2021
the trilateral counter group reached
another understanding
on resuming the ceasefire regime
nevertheless shootings shellings sniper
fire on ukrainian positions
and systematic use of attack uavs
against ukrainian troops have not
stopped
we have lost 12 servicemen killed in
action and 14 wounded since 22nd
december 2021.
just a few days ago on january 25 armed
formations of the russian federation
once again attacked the positions of the
armed forces of ukraine
in the area of bishopvic donetsk region
using an attack uav
vog-17
fragmentation grenades dropped from the
uav resulted in severe injuries to two
ukrainian servicemen
the current impasse
in the consultations process within the
framework of the tcg continues
on practically all tracks
while the decisions adopted by the
normandy format leaders during the
december 2019 summit in paris remain
unimplemented
over the past year and half we have seen
deliberate efforts by the russian side
to out to obstruct tcg activities and
even to prevent finalization of the
already agreed including at the expert
level arrangements within tcg in the
security and humanitarian areas
all this
is
accompanied by russia's stubborn denial
of being a party to the armed conflict
that has been raging for eight years now
in the donbass region of ukraine
attempts to impose a so-called direct
dialogue
with these puppet occupation
administrations
as well as refusal to engage in
substantive discussion on political
settlement of the conflict
the question is why all these russian
forces are there
we have asked this question on different
fora along with sending all clear
messages
ukraine is not going to launch military
offensive neither indones
nor in crimea nor anywhere else
ukraine sees no alternative to peaceful
resolution of the ongoing conflict
and restoration of its sovereignty and
territorial integrity
yet we also see a surge in russian
disinformation campaign including false
accusations of ukraine plotting a
military attack
this is not going to happen
this is direct evidence of russia's
unwillingness to escalate and prepare to
justify is possible for the aggression
we are well aware of russia's history of
ploys and provocations
and we will do everything possible to
prevent another
mynila type provocation by russia
once again
i have clear instructions
from my government
to reiterate today
the absence of any aggressive intention
as well as ukraine's strong commitment
to peace
today we have heard from the russian
side that they do not intend to launch a
war
against my country
although
one should rather speak about
to launch a new phase of the russian
aggression
it is very important message as we still
lack credible explanations by russia of
its actions and military movements
based on experience we cannot believe
russian declarations
but only practical moves on withdrawal
of troops from the border
madam president ukraine strongly rejects
any attempt to use the threat of force
as an instrument of pressure to make
ukraine and our partners accept
illegitimate demands
there is no room for compromise
on principle issues
the most principal position for ukraine
is that we have inherent sovereign right
to choose our own security arrangements
including
treaties of alliance which cannot be
questioned by russia
[Music]
moreover
this right is enshrined in many
international legal instruments that
russia itself a party
too ukraine will not bow to threats
aimed at weakening ukraine
undermining its economic and financial
stability
and inciting public frustration
this will not happen and the kremlin
must remember that ukraine is ready to
defend itself
at the same time we support
the need to keep diplomatic channels
with russia open
if that prevents a shift to military
tools
my president has reiterated most
recently
that he is ready to meet his russian
counterpart
[Music]
if russia has any questions to ukraine
it is better to meet and talk
not to bring troops to the ukrainian
buddhists
and intimidate ukrainian people
for ukraine the first priority today is
to achieve a sustainable and
unconditional ceasefire in the bus
the ceasefire regime must be guaranteed
reliable
and on these basis further steps can be
taken
intensification of the work of the
normandy former including at the level
of leaders
of the four countries
is an important prerequisite for next
steps towards lasting peace in the bus
and we are ready to resume normandy for
talks in all
the recent political advisors meeting on
26 january
in paris despite many differences
gives a hope for a continuation of the
negotiation process which ukraine
will staunchly support
madam president we consider that despite
the russian attempt to impede the
briefing from being held
the security council and the wider u.n
membership have received today a very
important information
information that the members of the
security council
need to take an informed decision
when appropriate
to act swiftly and decisively in
employing preventive diplomacy under the
chapter 6
of the u.n charter that rests on the
security council's responsibility to
investigate any dispute or any situation
which might lead to international
friction or give rise to a dispute
after listening to the russian
ambassador today i would like to ask how
long russia
will pressure
will pursue a clear attempt to push
ukraine and his partners into a kafka
trap
and still i perhaps should acknowledge
that it was important to hear the
russian envoy today
and yet i must end with what my foreign
minister has recently said and i quote
if russian officials are serious when
they say they don't want a new war
russia must continue diplomatic
engagement and pull back military forces
it amassed along ukraine's borders
and in the temporarily occupied
territories of ukraine
diplomacy is the only responsible way
end of quote
let's judge by actions
not by riddles and semantic puzzles
thank you for your attention
i thank the representative of ukraine
and i give the floor to the
representative of belarus
thank you
we have made significant efforts to
settle
our country is still prepared to do
everything possible to restore dialogue
and mutual understanding in the region
is
in ukraine to get on a sustainable
positive tracks
[Music]
[Music]
frequently by representatives
but rather it's becoming threatened
is
um
[Music]
numerous packages of economic sanctions
from individual states that have been
imposed against us
difficult situation the leaders of
belarus and russia have taken the
decision to conduct jointly activities
to provide military security
given the commitment of our ministry
agreements
has been taken in february this year
military forces is to assess the
preparedness and capability of our
military command and control to conduct
joint exercises to guarantee security
to
develop joints
measures to eradicate the threat
of our allied state
including caused by the migration crisis
and the need to stabilize the
humanitarian situation
organizing the defense and protection of
strategically important facilities
during defensive
during these drills there will be joint
drills
during joint
or our neighboring countries
foreign
ukrainian situation we'd like to remind
you that belarus is prepared to continue
to provide more necessary assistance to
settle the
and for negotiations in any possible
format and
see what
is
under
years ago now and this idea
unfortunately has not yet been improved
i thank the representative of belarus
and i give the floor to the
representative of poland
madam president madam under secretary
general
excellencies
poland is grateful for convening today's
meeting on the security council as we
are we are increasingly concerned with
russia's continuous large-scale military
buildup
on the border with ukraine both in the
territory of russia but also in the
territory of belarus
including continuous redeployments of
troops pre-positioning of military
hardware and offensive weapons
we cannot keep quiet because what is
happening in our neighborhood
constitutes a serious threat to
international peace and security
reaching far beyond our region and
continent
the current security situation in
eastern europe unfortunately follows a
pattern of precedence with the russian
federation being the destabilizing actor
in the region at least since the 2008
and the war in georgia 2014 an illegal
annexation of the crimean peninsula
as we speak
the frozen conflicts in eastern ukraine
in the georgian breakaway regions of
skin valley and abkhazia
and in the transnistrian region of the
republic of moldova are unresolved
undermining the stability and regional
security of this part of the world
madam president
we cannot keep quiet because what is
happening in our neighborhood
constitutes the outright violation of
the fundamental principles enshrined in
the u.n charter
poland deeply adheres the principles of
international law
such as sovereignty and tertiary
integrity of states then availability of
frontiers and then use our threat of
force
and we cannot and we call upon all
member states to act in the same spirit
we know very well from our country's
history that the political order based
on the spheres of influence brings no
positive results
it is here in the united nations when we
were it's our duty to protect the
principles of international law strongly
condemn any threat of use of force and
work together to dismantle spheres of
influence in order to maintain peace
what is at stake today it's not only the
subordination of ukraine and the
creation of the so-called buffer zone in
eastern central europe
the real threat is threat is to shake
the very foundation of the security
architecture in europe by undermining
such tenants of international laws and
viability of borders and the freedom to
choose one's own security arrangements
among others
unfortunately this may have a global
impact
and contribute to deterioration of
international security not to mention
the
possible humanitarian crisis
and there are no and there are other
revisionist powers which may follow this
youth
madam president
poland deeply believes in the power of
preventive diplomacy
holding the chairmanship in office of
the organization for security and
corporation europe
we stand open to facilitate talks on the
european security within the
organization
isc can provide the right venue to
discuss matters of concern because of
being the broadest of the regional
formats
we call for constructive engagement of
all participating states in order to
find a peaceful solution to the current
crisis
let there be no doubt that the current
status quo is not a solution at all
living in a constant fear of another
frozen conflict is against the
commitment of the these united nations
to practice tolerance and live together
in peace with one another as a good
neighbours
with winter olympics uh just uh less
than a week away
let us whatever we can
we'll
do whatever we can to maintain the
olympic peace
in the eastern europe and i thank you
i thank the representative of poland and
i give the floor to the representative
of lithuania
madam president let me thank you for
convening this meeting on such important
issue and for granting an opportunity to
speak
i am delivering this statement on behalf
of the baltic states estonia latvia and
my own country lithuania
firstly let me reiterate our country's
unwavering support for ukraine's
sovereignty independence and territorial
integrity within its internationally
recognized borders
we strongly condemn
the clear violation of ukraine's
sovereignty and territorial integrity by
acts of aggression by the russian armed
forces since february 2014
we do not recognize and continue to
condemn the illegal annexation ukraine's
autonomous republic of crimea and the
city of sevastopol by russia
we remain concerned over the increasing
militarization of the peninsula the
severe deterioration of the human rights
situation there
let me add in this context that we
welcome the establishment of the
international crimean platform launched
at the kickoff summit that took place on
23rd august in kiev and support the
implementation of its joint declaration
we invite other un members to join this
initiative as well
madam president the conflict in ukraine
has claimed around 14 000 lives
displaced 1.5 million persons and has
resulted in countless suffering on both
sides of the contact line in eastern
ukraine
we really through our full support to
the efforts towards peaceful and
sustainable resolution of this conflict
namely in the normandy format the
trilateral contact group and oac
including its special monitoring mission
to ukraine
yet despite all international efforts
until now we see little progress towards
the resolution
of this conflict ukraine's constructive
approach has not been reciprocated by
russia
we condemn russia's continued aggressive
actions and threats against ukraine and
call on russia to de-escalate the
situation and to abide by international
law
we call on russia to immediately stop
fueling the conflict by providing
financial and military support to the
armed formations
it backs and to withdraw the russian
military troops and materiel from the
eastern border of ukraine and crimean
peninsula
madam president
despite all diplomatic efforts russia
further escalates and continues military
deployment around ukraine's borders
moreover russian troops are deployed in
belarus as well
this adds up to the current escalation
and is of direct concern to us
kremlin continues to use a false
narrative that russia is forced to
defend itself
from a threat even as the opposite is
true it is russia who is threatening
ukraine and other neighbors by
positioning over 100 000 troops or she's
not a victim as it attempts to portray
itself it is the aggressor
strengthening its security at the
expense of others
by its own actions in the georgian
breakaway regions of south ossetia and
abkhazia the transition region the
illegal annexation of crimea russia has
contributed to a significant
deterioration of security environment in
europe
we reaffirm reaffirm full commitment to
the core principles of international
security enshrined in the u.n charter
founding documents of the oasis osc
including the helsinki final act and the
charter of paris and others
this includes notably the sovereign
equality and territorial integrity of
states
the invaluability of frontiers
refraining from the use of force
their violation of by russia is an
obstacle to a common and indivisible
security space in europe and threatens
peace and stability in our continent
times of limited sovereignty in europe
are long gone
notions of spheres of influence have no
place in the 21st century states have
freedom to choose or change their own
security arrangements
no third country has a veto right over
the sovereign choices of independent and
democratic states
madam president in response to the
recent tensions the eu has made clear in
the december and january european
council conclusions that any further
military aggression against ukraine will
have massive consequences and severe
costs including restrictive measures to
be coordinated closed with our
transatlantic partners
modern presidents president we call on
russia to respect principles of u.n
charter de-escalate and engaged in
genuine dialogue it is our duty as
members of the un to defend the
rules-based international system
violation of its fundamental principles
we have the consequences for other parts
of the world i thank you madam president
i thank the representative of lithuania
there are no more names inscribed on the
list of speakers the meeting is
adjourned